what is more important the perception of
how we see a thing or what that thing
really is and i'm going to give you an
example what the thing really is what's
more important the fact that martin
luther king is the man that we see that
fought for freedom or the fact that he
was cheating on his wife
jesus i think oh
no move he's a great father he's a great
father he's a great businessman he's a
great ceo he's an entrepreneur he's such
a boss he's such a boss he's a boss look
at that man he's a boss
he's a great father look at him that
strong black man but you're cheating on
your wife you're not a good husband
you're not a good communicator you don't
value her feelings but he's great in all
these other aspects
how are you a great leader a great ceo a
great black man a great father
a great a great leader in any aspect
you're not a great husband
a great communicator a great you're a
liar
you're not you're not great
you're not great you're a liar you're
not great so that's so that's my you're
not great so i posted this
god you're not
are you great
because we don't know if you're great at
this one
we don't know
that is triggering yeah oh i'm a good
dad you're not a good dad cause you
don't respect me how the [ __ ] you
showing these kids you a good father or
you don't respect their mother
how are you a good father you don't
respect who brought them into this world
carried them
you're not a great dad my [ __ ]
if we take the example of stating the
example of martin luther king okay he's
not great
because china's please subscribe
to your business
that's between you and whatever so
that's one thing the second thing is
stop putting [ __ ] on the
pedestal whether it be superstars
whether it be pastors whether it be to
all these [ __ ] are human
all these [ __ ] are human it's
not so much yeah they did some [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was wrong right right we have
a responsibility of putting them on a
pedestal they just human beings
that decided to do something different
and then you like what they do that's it
if i'm a good person to you i i posted
this on my it's on my post and i posted
on my stories before but someone being a
good person to you means they are a good
person to you
someone being a good person to everyone
means that they are a good person
and that's that's my point but you can't
be a good person to everyone because
everybody got two sides to it there's
three sides to a story my side your side
what happened
okay that's three sides
now you cannot be a good person to
everybody because you're gonna be
entitled to your reason of you acting a
certain way to some [ __ ] i'm
gonna have a reason to think you're a
[ __ ] what is the consistency of your
character
you cannot say
that you are a good husband or you are a
good wife because let's make it gender
neutral
about just this is a this is a humanity
conversation we're just talking broadly
and there were times where i had to
stand in my truth and be like i wasn't a
good wife going back to martin luther
king
did we need to know that he was a
cheater
jesus
would that have shifted the way we
looked at him looked at him and received
information from him i can't take this
girl seriously the irony of this whole
thing they're talking about
was he a good man was this black man a
good man and they're using the fact that
he cheated against him it's the exact
same tactic that the fbi used to try to
discredit martin luther king at that
time it says a lot that you use the
exact same language that the feds use to
try to discredit his message during the
civil rights movement you have in a way
taken up the very role that the
oppressive fbi used against martin
luther king
congratulations
you played yourself i mean the mere fact
that you can get on this podcast and
have the ability to pontificate and all
say all this stupid [ __ ] is very likely
due to people like martin luther king
who fought for your right to do so
if that doesn't make him great alone i
don't know what is because you wouldn't
even be up here to say all this dumb
[ __ ] about how potentially not great he
is he cheated he cheated he's such a bad
person how does the wife feel she's fine
with it so then shut your [ __ ] mouth
it's not your relationship she's come
out and say i got an issue with it our
bond was special no problems
it's not your place me listen to this
stuff you know the way people talk about
cheating you would think is [ __ ]
murder well you know this man freed a
billion slaves
stopped the aliens from taking over the
world he cheated on his wife what about
a great [ __ ] loser
what a [ __ ] loser
did he not consider her feelings while
he was out there slamming all those
little dark people huh say that again
delete because they're all her feelings
what a [ __ ] loser
what a [ __ ] loser
she's hurting at home right now what
about in her titties she's hurting what
about her what huh what about her
[ __ ] feelings feelings
[ __ ] feelings
look at his face
[ __ ] feelings
i
i wish his stories would just get
together
and consider the legacy of every
historical figure and be like well we
understand that uh he advanced england
into the new age but he cheated on
i mean yeah it's okay they take it
personal i can understand someone's
taking it personal i think i think a lot
of folks have to come hold on hold on
hold on okay go ahead maya angelou
i'm not even gonna do it am i am i
what was my angel doing before she was
writing books
tricking
[ __ ] her then
no what a disgrace
no no no no no no she's not who we think
she is every quote oh hell no every
great quote that helped me advance or
great books
throw that [ __ ] in the trash listen
before anybody is quote-unquote great
they're human they're capable of good
they're killable back people knew that
about martin luther king the reason why
they fixed it on the good is because it
overwhelmingly
was much more important than the bad
we all do this in our day-to-day lives
we look at the good and the bad but the
way that you're having this conversation
it's almost like you're putting the two
things on an equal level he was a great
leader a great thing he also cheated
that does not put him what who cares
jesus christ like every great person
that you can think of has a huge
character flaw they got anger issues
some of them were violent for long
periods of time you know some of them
have alcohol substance abuse issues they
got past criminal records like it's very
rare
that you meet somebody who's great and
then is squeaky clean and if they are
they got some deep ass skeletons in
their closet
we all got problems and if we're honest
enough when we're looking at anybody on
these platforms or these people making
these speeches if we look at them long
enough we would stop trying to demand
that they try to be perfect because they
not
who cares
unless they say if you can contribute
more than you take away from
civilization that is fantastic maybe
you're not the best father maybe you're
not the best husband okay
you out there saving people every day
guess what you're a net benefit to
society maybe not to one or two people
right to those that
okay and and whatever have your issues
doesn't define you entirely but for you
to sit there and be like well he cheated
so
[ __ ] this is complicated
that's it
one thing
by that logic you ma'am or a shitty ass
wife because at one point in your life
you were a bad wife according to your
own words so you're shitty so because
mlk did some mistakes in his marriage
well should we quit what are we talking
about got you and allowed him to lead us
would we trust a man that cheats on his
wife
yes
you have trusted men who cheated on
their wives
listen your daddy probably cheated on
his wife
there's plenty of people out there who
cheated that you probably never even
knew and you followed the direction
everything went well it's not because
you have infidelity at home that's
inherently mean you're a bad person
everywhere else
not that we don't know that he is i
think everybody kind of knew in that
time what was going on but even like
what you said we talked about this
previously with a deeper discussion what
you said about coretta you were like
even
how she covered him and honored her
husband she covered him
she covered him and honored her husband
because i'm not she could have blasted
him if coretta was in 2020 what would
happen
it doesn't matter if she wasn't and
that's none of your business and she's
okay with it so move on
now now she's saying like i know how you
would have acted if it was today you
don't know [ __ ] you don't know [ __ ]
about it there's two people today
who have husbands who are out there with
other women and they have an
understanding you don't know [ __ ] about
[ __ ] so
let me tell you something
vast majority of presidents have affairs
but what you would you think you think
these people who live in washington are
all faithful to their wives
do you see their wives putting them on
blast no why because they have an
understanding ain't the clinton's still
together
guess what
guess what
it's none of my business nobody cares i
think a lot of people have like a
juvenile understanding of
older generations relationship dynamics
and stuff like that
just i don't know to me when i hear this
stuff talk about um he hurt her feelings
he was like jesus christ grow the [ __ ]
up
grow up
the world doesn't just revolve around
everything that you feel it's not always
about your hurt or your pain
some people when they get into a
marriage they aspire to other things
just like i was like oh i'm hurt i feel
there's bigger things for some folks
maybe it's not for you and that's okay
but for you to put that paradigm on
everybody like
there's nobody people live like that
every single day all over the globe
on instagram on instagram i'm not
committed to you
i'm committed to the purpose i'm
committed to my position in this purpose
in this purpose
but am i committed to you or am i
committed to our purpose i'm commit she
was committed to the purpose that's not
in your business
that's not your business
maybe she was committed to him you don't
know
you don't know because now you're not
thinking like her you're thinking like
you in that like what you think you
would have done in that situation first
and foremost you are not in that
situation you will never be in that
situation because that time has passed
that time has passed
that time has passed it happened when
you was not even born and it was a
different
situation you don't know how you would
have reacted oh me no no you don't know
stop
stop
stop
does nobody give a [ __ ] ain't it weird
to like look at [ __ ] from the 1920s
1930s and be like let me judge it with
today's statement yeah you can stop you
sh stop that's very that's very
delicious delusional what you're doing
right now but
do you boo boo do you you know you don't
know what you would do four years
forever look i'm okay what how did he
feel about trans folks it's like
yeah
you can't stop was he really a great
person uh
what kind of pronouns was he comfortable
using when it comes to other people stop
that's asinine that's just stupid [ __ ]
that's not even a point
superstar
malcolm x only believes in the gender
binary
score
you think you said something you didn't
say
you said you didn't say [ __ ] you didn't
say wow bro
your business but whatever it's
interesting i think the phenomenon
exists because when you're hearing about
an issue of the past even though it's
happening in the past you don't
understand it in that context you're
always living in your own you're living
it as if it's now yeah that's why like
even if you said the n word 40 years ago
right even though you may never said it
since if a video surfaces now everyone
loses their mind right and years ago was
not even the same context as right now
ten years ago
five years ago was not the same context
as now yeah
this is five yeah so you want to take my
you want to take martin
yeah i'll go drink some water
crazy
anyway let us know what you guys think
in the comments below